In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 16th, on which we commemorate the Holy and
Great Martyr, Ophemia, the All-Famed.
On the 16th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy and Great Martyr, Ophemia
of Calcedon.
Great Ophemia lived at Calcedon in the reign of Diocletian in the years 284 through 305.
Her parents were rich and devout and brought her up in the love of Christ.
At that time, Priscus became Pro-Consul of Asia and ordered all the inhabitants of the province
to come to Calcedon to celebrate the feast of his God, under pain of death.
Whereupon the Christians fled in small groups to isolated houses or to the deserts in
order to escape the tyrant and safeguard their faith.
Saint Ophemia was among those who went into hiding, and by her virtue and wisdom shown
as a bright star amid her 49 companions.
They were soon discovered and brought before the Pro-Consul who tried to persuade them
to sacrifice by flattering their youth and good sense.
Do not waste your time and your words on us, the saints answered him.
We are people endowed with reason for whom it would be the greatest disgrace to abandon
the one true God, the maker of heaven and earth, in order to worship dumb, senseless idols.
We are not afraid of the torments you threaten us with.
They will be easy for us to bear, and will show you the power of our God.
These words enraged the Pro-Consul, and he had Ophemia and her companions tortured continuously
for twenty days.
Then finding their faith completely unshaken and seeing that Ophemia was the leading spirit
of the group, he ordered her limbs to be crushed by iron wheels.
But the martyr called upon the help of God and was discovered to be completely unscathed.
Then she was cast into a furnace with flames forty feet high.
But God came to Ophemia's aid there also and sent an angel who drew the flames away from
her.
Even this miracle, the executioner's victor and sostenies turned to Christ and died as
martyrs some days later at the teeth of the beasts.
The saint had many more torments to endure, from which God each time delivered her, showing
how much stronger grace is than any torture the malice of men can devise.
In the end she was thrown to the beasts and gave up her soul to God through the mere
bite of a bear.
When the persecution of Diocletian ended, the Christians laid Saint Ephemias relics in
a golden sarcophagus, placed within a church that was dedicated to her.
On her feast day there would flow from her tomb a stream of fresh blood, having a heavenly
scent.
The miraculous rejection of the tomb of the heretics during the Council of Calcedon
in the year 451 also occurred at her shrine, see the commemoration for July 11th.
Her relics attracted crowds of pilgrims for centuries.
They were translated to Constantinople in the year 616 at the time of the Persian invasions
and remain intact to this day in the church of the Patriarchate at the Fennar.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.